[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de cette chance que
vous me donnez de porter la voix de
milliers de chercheuses et de chercheurs
dans le monde
alors je voudrais commencer par une
question vous avez déjà entendu parler
du réchauffement climatique avez-vous
déjà entendu parler de la sensibilité du
climat
la sensibilité du climat moi je l'ai
rencontré quand j'étais lycéenne à Nancy
pour ça que c'est assez émouvant pour
moi d'être ici il y a 35 ans par hasard
en feuilleton un magazine scientifique
dans le CDI de mon lycée
dans cet article dans ce magazine
scientifique il y avait un article sur
le progrès de l'observation de la Terre
depuis l'espace un article sur les
travaux de modélisation du climat passé
et futur fait en France et un article
sur les reconstructions de l'évolution
de passer du climat et des gaz à effet
de serre dans l'atmosphère à partir de
carottage en Antarctique et je me
souviens de ce moment de vertige quand
j'ai pris conscience que l'influence
humaine par la combustion d'énergie
fossile en particulier
altéré en fait la composition de
l'atmosphère à l'échelle planétaire et
que le climat allait bien sûr continuer
à y réagir
alors cette sensibilité du climat
qu'est-ce que c'est
j'ai choisi en fait le défi le plus
grand pour parler de changement
climatique je vais pas trop vous parler
des risques je vais pas trop vous parler
des solutions mais vraiment de la
machine climatique la sensibilité du
climat c'est lorsqu'on perturbe le bilan
d'énergie de la Terre le résultat de
l'ensemble des processus amplificateurs
et stabilisateurs qu'on appelle des
rétroactions et sa mesure le
réchauffement à la surface de la Terre
une fois qu'on a doublé le niveau de
dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère par
rapport au climat pré industriel
ce qui est assez fascinant c'est que la
sensibilité du climat elle était déjà
évaluée en 1979 dans un rapport de
l'Académie des Sciences américaines et
le jugement d'expert de l'époque avec
des outils bien moins développés
qu'aujourd'hui était une meilleure
estimation autour de 3 degrés mais avec
une incertitude très large entre 1 degré
et demi et 4 degrés et demi alors
pourquoi est-ce que c'est important
c'est important parce qu'en fait la
sensibilité du climat c'est ce qui va
définir la réponse du climat à nos
rejets de gaz à effet de serre c'est ce
qui va définir la marge de manœuvre qui
nous reste en termes d'émissions
possible de gaz à effet de serre si on
veut stabiliser le réchauffement à tel
ou tel niveau c'est ce qui relie nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre au
niveau de réchauffement planétaire si la
sensibilité est faible un peu moins si
la sensibilité est forte un peu plus
pour la même quantité de gaz à effet de
serre émis
alors un mot sur le niveau de
réchauffement planétaire on en est à 1
degré virgule 1 depuis la fin du 19e
siècle c'est déjà une rupture sur plus
de 2000 ans ça entraîne des impacts
généralisés dans chaque région des
dépérissements de forêt des dégradations
de récifs de coraux une baisse du
potentiel de prise de pêche dans les
régions tropicales des tendances des
extrêmes des événements qui dépassent
déjà certains seuils de tolérance et
plus le niveau de réchauffement va
continuer à monter plus en fait on aura
une amplification des multiples facettes
des caractéristiques d'un climat qui
change dans chaque région beaucoup en
fait de caractéristiques du climat
dépendent immédiatement directement du
niveau de réchauffement planétaire c'est
le cas du niveau de réchauffement en
France ou sur les continents plus marqué
que la moyenne planète Terre
c'est le cas de l'intensification des
extrêmes chauds des plus extrêmes ou des
sécheresses
plus le curseur monte plus ce sont aussi
des effets en cascade sur les
écosystèmes et les sociétés qui ont
dépendant des risques de plus en plus
complexes difficiles à gérer par exemple
des extrêmes à la fois chaud et secs qui
vont toucher la capacité de travail
physique en extérieur et donc les
revenus de ceux qui en dépendent les
rendements agricoles augmentant le coût
de l'alimentation avec des conséquences
en termes de santé ou de malnutrition et
on a dans le monde plus de 3 milliards
de personnes qui vivent dans des
contextes hautement vulnérables par
rapport au changement climatique
les effets immédiats mais aussi des
effets à long terme pour un niveau de
réchauffement donné les glaciers mettent
des décennies à s'ajuster l'océan
profonde des siècles et puis le
Groenland de l'Antarctique des milliers
d'années et donc le pic de réchauffement
qu'on aura qu'on choisira d'avoir dans
quelques décennies ou plus tard ça va
déterminer aussi l'ampleur de la montée
du niveau de la mer à l'échec de siècle
et de milliers d'années donc la
sensibilité du climat en fait c'est ce
qui va façonner ce qui nous touche
partout et aussi notre héritage quelque
part les effets et irréversibles à très
long terme
alors dans mon parcours professionnel
j'ai touché à la sensibilité du climat
j'ai travaillé sur la confrontation de
simulation de grands changements
climatique passé avec les
reconstitutions issues d'archives
naturelles du climat c'est important en
fait de s'assurer que les modèles de
climat qui représentent les processus
physiques mis au point pour le climat
actuel représente bien en fait les
grandes caractéristiques des changements
glaciers des changements passés les
périodes glaciaires ou les périodes
géologiques très chaudes
et puis en reconstituant les variations
de température à l'aide de carottage en
Antarctique à l'échelle des derniers
800000 ans j'ai contribué à apporter une
pièce de puzzle parmi d'autres 800 000
ans ça peut vous paraître très lointain
mais en fait ce sont les variations
glaciaires interglaciaires certains
changements abruptent les petites
variations pendant les périodes douces
qui ont été le berceau de l'émergence de
l'espèce humaine actuelle Homo sapiens
dont les vestiges les plus anciens ont
environ 300.000 ans
et donc en combinant cette pièce de
puzzle avec les autres informations
issues des autres archives naturelles du
climat le travail de modélisation des
climat passé on avait déterminé qu'il y
avait une possibilité de mettre une
borne inférieure et une borne supérieure
à cette sensibilité du climat on avait
aussi montré que cette sensibilité du
climat c'est pas une constante c'est pas
une caractéristique physique
permanente et que plus le climat est
chaud plus elle est forte
et puis cette histoire ne s'arrête pas
là en 2015 le gouvernement français m'a
demandé de présenter ma candidature pour
être qu'au présidente du groupe de
travail du GIEC donc qui fournit une
évaluation de l'état des connaissances
sur les bases physiques du changement
climatique j'ai mis en fait plusieurs
mois à me décider j'ai longtemps hésité
parce que d'abord j'étais pas sûr d'en
être capable et puis ensuite parce que
je pensais que ça m'empêcherait d'avoir
du temps pour faire ma propre recherche
ça prendrait aussi beaucoup de temps sur
ma vie de famille en fait j'avais raison
ça a tout écrasé ça ça a tout écrasé et
le 9 août 2021 je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de ce que vous faisiez
le neveu août 2021 donc il y avait
l'arrivée Lionel Messi au PSG qui a
beaucoup mobilisé le traitement
médiatique de l'actualité et avec mon
collègue chinois avec lequel j'ai porté
ce travail pendant des années nous on a
présenté depuis un hôtel à Évry
Courcouronnes le résultat d'un travail
collectif sur l'état des connaissances
vis-à-vis du changement climatique et
les points clés de notre évaluation
alors ce rapport du jet vous envoyez la
couverture et une œuvre d'artistes qui
ont présente en fait certains aspects
climat global climat régional la
compréhension de l'état actuel du
système climatique et l'influence
humaine qui est prépondérante les futurs
possibles en fonction de nos choix en
termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre une information climatique à
l'échelle régionale là où c'est
important pour éclairer la gestion de
risque les stratégies d'adaptation et
puis les conditions en fait géophysiques
les contraintes géophysiques qui
permettraient de stabiliser le
réchauffement
alors si on revient en 2015 quand tout
ça a démarré tout au départ en fait on a
voulu changer la structure de ce type de
rapport on voulait pas d'aborder en silo
les observations d'un côté les modèles
de l'autre les climats passés d'un côté
et le reste on a complètement changé la
structure de notre rapport ou d'une part
pour répondre aux attentes exprimées par
les différents pays en particulier
d'information régionale mais aussi pour
favoriser une approche holistique
c'est-à-dire où on mobilise toutes les
sources d'information ce qu'on tire des
climats passés ce qu'on tire de la
compréhension des processus ce qu'on
tire des observations actuelles et des
contraintes qui en viennent
et en faisant cela une avancée majeure
dans le nouveau chapitre qui porte sur
le bilan d'énergie de la Terre les
rétroactions et la sensibilité du climat
c'est d'être parvenu à confirmer
l'intuition des années 1979 c'est à dire
une sensibilité du climat avec une
meilleure estimation à trois degrés mais
avec un socle scientifique bien plus
robuste et d'avoir réduit d'un facteur 2
la plage d'incertitude sur cette
sensibilité du climat et en particulier
en réduisant l'incertitude associée au
fonctionnement des nuages dont on sait
maintenant qu'ils ont un effet nette
amplificateur sur la réponse de la
machine climatique
ça fait penser que quand j'étais enfant
je m'ennuyais parfois en cours et
j'aimais regarder par la fenêtre et
rêver en regardant les nuages je les
regarde un peu autrement et peut-être
vous aussi vous les regardez autrement
en pensant leur rôle dans le
fonctionnement du climat à l'échelle
planétaire
alors en utilisant cette cette avancée
des connaissances on a pu en fait
contraindre les projections d'évolution
future c'est à dire que pour une
trajectoire d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre donnée on a une estimation en fait
beaucoup plus précise de l'évolution de
la température à la surface de la Terre
au niveau planétaire et on a fait la
même chose vis-à-vis de l'ampleur de la
montée du niveau de la mer
j'espère que ça va vous donner envie de
parcourir ce rapport et des étudiants en
école d'ingénieurs récemment m'ont
demandé quel était le chapitre le plus
dur à lire j'aurais dit celui sur la
sensibilité du climat c'est là en fait
on a les choses les plus abstraites les
plus dures mais en fait ça reflète les
gains qui ont été faits par des
décennies de recherche en sciences
fondamentale et les résultats majeurs
qui ont été obtenus récemment et qui ont
une importance considérable vis-à-vis de
l'évolution du climat planétaire on va
attendre un degré et demi dans les
prochains vingt ans il faut s'y préparer
mobiliser les connaissances qui existent
pour anticiper faire en sorte que ce
qu'on met en place soit résilient le
plus possible
et puis si on veut stabiliser le
réchauffement diminuer environ 30% les
rejets de méthane cette décennie
diminuer entre un quart et la moitié des
rejets de dioxyde de carbone dans le
monde cette décennie il y a des options
pour le faire et attendre le plus vite
possible des émissions mondiales dues
aux activités humaines à net 0 ça veut
dire en fait pour des ingénieurs par
exemple aujourd'hui chercher le plus de
rupture possibles pour atteindre cela le
plus précocement possible
j'essaie de vous montrer ce travail en
fait collectif de génération de
chercheuses et chercheurs au suivant le
temps partout dans le monde mais
finalement à quoi sert un rapport du
GIEC quand on le rédige c'est à la fois
une joie de travailler avec l'ensemble
des chercheurs impliqués leur énergie
l'émulation qui est dedans l'esprit
critique tout le temps c'est une immense
responsabilité pour leur donner les
meilleures conditions pour le préparer
dans un contexte de pandémie il y a pas
mal d'obstacles là surmonté pour
parvenir à finaliser en travaillant à
distance
ça permet de faire une maturation des
connaissances scientifiques on distingue
les choses robustes les choses nouvelles
les choses associées à un degré de
confiance élevé au moins mais aussi les
verrous scientifiques ce qui reste à
produire comme connaissance nouvelle
c'est un socle scientifique qui est
reconnu approuvé mot par mot phrase par
phrase par les représentants de tous les
pays donc dans les semaines avant le 9
août 2021 c'était 186 heures sur zoom
avec les représentants de tous les pays
pour finaliser le résumé pour les
décideurs
c'est tout un travail de communication
un atlas interactif les données sont
accessibles des résumés de deux pages
par région tout est en ligne
et puis c'est revoir les points clés de
ce rapport faire partie du pacte de
glace Go à l'issue des négociations sur
le climat à l'automne dernier après la
COP 26 premier préambule reconnu par
tous les pays science et urgences la
gravité des impacts observés dans chaque
région l'urgence à agir une décennie
critique baisser les rejets de gaz à
effet de serre de l'ordre de moitié
d'ici à 2030 et atteindre net 0 CO2
d'ici à 2050 si on veut stabiliser le
réchauffement à un niveau proche d'un
degré et demi une forte baisse des
émissions de méthane donc le constat
scientifique il est devant les
responsable de tous les pays ils le
connaissent ils l'ont repris
mais un rapport du Gex à notre sens que
s'il est lu ça n'absence que s'il est
partagé j'ai essayé de vous montrer
l'énergie incroyable de milliers de
scientifiques ce rapport c'est 234
chercheuses et chercheurs de 65 pays 600
contributeurs qui ont passé en revue les
éléments probants de 14000 publications
c'est près de 2000 relecteurs 80 000
commentaires de relecture pris en compte
pour fournir un socle scientifique le
plus précis possible et de la manière le
plus clair possible
je résume en fait en disant que on
montre à quel point chaque incrément de
réchauffement évité supplémentaires
compte à quel point chaque tonne de CO2
de méthane évité compte vis-à-vis des
risques liés au climat et au final à
quel point chaque choix compte et donc
profondément ce que j'espère c'est que
cette présentation très courte elle vous
donnera envie de vous appuyer sur ce
socle de connaissances le plus récent de
contribuer à les faire avancer
je vais parler de sensibilité du climat
le mot sensibilité il est beau en fait
c'est une force d'être sensible est-ce
que vous êtes sensible aux sciences du
climat est-ce que vous êtes sensible au
risque est-ce que vous êtes sensible aux
options d'action qui existent et qui
sont disponibles évalués dans les autres
volets des rapports du GIEC est-ce que
vous aurez la même énergie à mettre en
route tout ce qui est possible pour agir
le plus rapidement possible vos choix
comptent merci
[Applaudissements]